[Music]
so I thought about we just watch this
this scene Taylor you have this an
incredible fight scene this season very
intense I understand what made it more
intense for you guys which we didn't
know is this was your first time that
you've thrown a punch on camera is that
right news oh yes were you nervous very
nervous I was like who is more nervous
were you nervous when you found out that
this fight scene was going to be those
first time really whaling away at you
know I who's as strong yeah very strong
woman I trusted her we did you know I
was scared I'd we just kept talking
about you know I'm a person and I have a
face and your face is the money we
communicated a lot with her I yeah we
did a lot of like locked in I was like
please don't ruin the show but ya know
I'm not very good at doing that yeah
you're not a natural like you're
obviously a terrific actor but but
sometimes you have to know stage combat
was not your thing it wasn't it wasn't
you know I took stage combat classes in
school when I learned about school they
don't really do that girl I went to talk
show host school was there for nine
years yeah did you never finish never
finish
I'm doing this for my credits is an
internship ya know I didn't do very well
in stage combat I had we tried they
tried to teach me how to fence I failed
I didn't do that very well right I tried
to learn how to punch things and just
kept hitting the air but you know what's
interesting you never write this season
your character Piper has really taken it
up and you become much tougher and now
that's an important part of your
character is your intensity and your
physicality do you feel like you're
getting the hang of it that was
intimidating now Jason you don't have
you have a lot of scenes but you're
never in really you don't have prison
scenes and it seems like you're missing
out on some of the action there if you
ever feel as an actor you wish your
character would hang out in the prison
more often yeah I do I have a little
Prison envy I'm not gonna lie I do well
I will say this I will say like these
these ladies have the I mean really seem
to have the best time unless you guys
are bullshitting it seems like you guys
really love each other and have the best
time and and I you know I have the best
scene partner in the world and Taylor
Schilling I mean most of my scenes are
just with her but I wish I would get to
be in on the prison fun and craziness
and lesbian sex etc it's gonna be very
hard to figure out a way for you to buy
it on the view it may be you have a
troubled twin sister
yeah
[Applause]
you